head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
White House violated ethics guideline by
deleting I like how to say it fat chat
fact check tweet saying Biden had given
American seniors the biggest boost in
Social Security the reason I want to
bring this up first and foremost the
White House violated ethics by deleting
public record but someone super chatted
this to us and forgive me for not
remembering your name they superintended
saying is it even legal for Biden to
delete public records from the White
House Twitter account that's public
record and lo you were correct so here
we go this is how I guess broken the
White House is they try passing off a
lie and when they get caught they
violate ethics to try and get away with
it now it's only made it worse which is
another example of the Biden
Administration they're digging their
hole deeper someone should make a sitcom
about this guy you know a sitcom about
buying I'd watch that because hey wait
wait there is at a laugh track yeah add
a laugh track to you ever see
um those viral videos of like friends
with no laugh track yeah it's so weird
and it's really creepy we could tell
totally take a Biden speech and just add
laughs and it would be like a comedy or
you know binding walking around or
whatever I'm kind of like I I was more
comfortable when they were lying to me
and I didn't know with George Bush Jr
and the Iraq War at least then I was
like oh they lied everyone kind of
agreed hey they shouldn't have done that
we mostly yelled back like don't do that
anymore now it's like
when it's happening in real time and
it's becomes apparent I'm I'm guess I'm
glad it's happening out in the open now
because where you can see it and we can
criticize it I think that's an important
part of this process
like because it was always happening I
guess and I criticized it too is another
question yeah as long as you don't make
unfounded claims
hmm yeah according to who according to
them according to me sir
man seeing the the Ivory Tower crumble
When Donald Trump got elected the first
time I likened it to there's an ivory
Tower and there you know the left-wing
populace and the right-wing populists
come up to the doors and they're yawn
rabble rabble rabble and then you know
pelosian Schumer and the clintons and
Obama they're looking out the window
with their pinkies out drinking wine
going oh the rebel is trying to get in
the building Bernie Sanders knocked on
the door they splashed water on his head
and said get out of here and he went oh
okay I'm sorry about that and then he
left and then the other group of rhyming
populists leave come back with a ball
and then they look down going oh crap
and then Donald Trump who's the bull
smashes the door in and starts rampaging
through the Ivory Tower and I find it
hilarious you know there are people who
are like Donald Trump is a fascist
destroying this country and I was like
I'm just imagining all of these uppity
Elites laugh like like terrified that
Donald Trump is doing these things and
it makes me happy yeah that's all I can
say whatever it's not my choice but now
I'm looking at where we are with with
Twitter
since then it's like Sledgehammer has
been taken to the base of the Ivory
Tower and it's on the verge of crumbling
and they're and they're looking out the
window going stop stop if you let them
keep doing this democracy will end and
it's like okay dude you're up there
we're down here sorry I'm not listening
so you know I'm kind of looking forward
to Tuesday you know the White House they
can violate ethics all day and night and
there it's it's the desperation it's
become an ugly perfume how about that so
should we Sue or should somebody sue the
White House for uh violating ethics
Clause well I don't know how you handle
this I mean I don't know either maybe we
need to make sure that if any
Republicans do win we're screaming in
their faces like figuratively no you
need inquiries we want subpoenas we want
criminal referrals we have to wait until
Facebook fact checks this so we know
exactly what they think about it and
then we can move forward confidently
knowing that we're we're appropriately
informed judiciously the White House
should keep the Tweet up and then the
fact check should be there as public
record and they should comment on the
fact check they but they can't the issue
was Biden accidentally said
the high inflation is my fault they said
Social Security is going up because of
Biden's leadership but it was only going
up trade it was triggered by an
automatic it was an automatic trigger
due to high inflation so he basically
said that high inflation you're
suffering from is because of me whoops
you need to delete that so they were
like we got to get rid of that I used
the phrase through Biden's leadership so
you could you could Define that in a
couple of ways one is like through his
hard work this happened as a result of
his hard work or you could say like yeah
through 2022 we did all this it wasn't
like 2022 did it to us we just did it
through the process of his him being
leader so in that sense you could argue
that yes Social Security did go up
through the period of his leadership but
I think that they were insinuating that
he just brought up so much more
attention to this bull crap they just
literally they uh Barbra Streisand did
this to such a high level that we're
still talking about how they inflated
the economy to the point that they're
giving out record Social Security checks
I mean this is beautiful it's it's
awesome and and again this is mainly
because of you know the change at
Twitter I don't think this would happen
if Elon Musk wasn't at Twitter no they
won't stop the community
exactly agreed yeah and then and then
someone would tweet out the White House
is lying about the social security thing
and it's only happening because of
inflation and then it would be locked it
would get a red exclamation point and it
would say election interference fake
news
that's what they they just did that to
Jesse Kelly I'm pretty sure they locked
one of his tweets he said something like
if you can't count the votes in a day
and they're still cheating or whatever
that's right well dude
people are allowed to have opinions and
if someone's like I don't like it that
we have a month of voting sorry we're
going to lock your account because of
that there's there's that's that's
clearly bunk but I gotta tell you Elon
Musk has gotten rid of the ethics
accountability and transparency
curation and moderation so what I will
say
going into this weekend is going to be
very interesting because uh
there's nobody at Twitter
the offices are all closed and
everyone's locked out until Monday
the only people who are still there are
critical infrastructure
does that include
content moderation there's pros and cons
that means you can be algorithmically
locked out of your account and there's
nobody there to fix it it could also
mean that there's nobody there to lock
you out of your account
right before the midterm elections it's
a free-for-all yeah so we might this is
kind of like um
you know it's it's like the the the the
powers the meme magic was suppressed and
locked away by dark Forces and then Elon
Musk he comes into this tomb with
carrying a torch and he sees this large
green frog-shaped rock and then he
strikes it with a hammer and then it
cracks and then green me magic bursts we
may actually see a glimpse of the power
of the meme Magic from 2016 with all of
these people being removed from Twitter
it's going to be like it was where
people are posting jokes constantly the
memes go viral everyone's laughing
having a good time and then Maga
Republicans get memed into office no
maybe it's the midterm if Elon Musk
pulls this off 2023 is going to be crazy
2024 is going to get even crazier oh
yeah the memes the great meme War 3 is
upon us I'm just here for the memes I
don't care who wins I don't care who's
in office as long as we just have the
memes I got an idea for uh Sheamus for
Freedom Tunes it's a guy pulling up like
an old computer laptop and like blowing
the dust off of it and wiping it away
and opening it up and there's a big
folder that says memes and then he
double clicks and he's like we're back
you can dust him off bring them out
bring out all the old memes
did you guys ever see the uh the Donald
Trump Keck meme magic mini documentary
Yes actually I have yeah just talking
about how like the ancient god Keck was
a frog and then oh yes was World of
Warcraft dude that's so crazy yeah I
vaguely I think I remember this stuff
see we we see this is the crazy thing
there was a brief moment where we
started to understand the power of memes
and I don't mean literal magic I mean
Community organizing but then this this
video came out talking about how people
meming this stuff was actually having an
impact on politics they destroyed it and
now we're going back to this curated
top-down world that sucks like when
there were three TV channels you can't
stop the meme though that's why I came
in blazing about graphene when I started
on the show and I just I wanted to set a
meme standard I'm the graph I'm the meme
guy I'm the graphing guy now when you
think of graphene you think of me that
was my intention I memed it into
existence
when people say things like uh you know
Twitter's not real life I think it's a
misunderstanding of the dynamic that the
internet as with relation to politics
and things like that like actually the
things that happen on platforms like
Twitter can ultimately influence they
they do influence elections and
otherwise the left would not be trying
so hard to maintain control over Twitter
if that wasn't the case right and I mean
you're seeing this in the mainstream
people are saying that you know what
potential changes must can bring to the
platform uh are a threaten to the
outcome of Ben Collins actually was the
one that said this that it could
threaten the midterm elections but if
Twitter a change in management has the
power to threaten elections then that
means that Twitter already has the
control over this and somehow uh control
of the discourse in a way that's
consequential
so I think yeah I think the the meme
magic is really just getting at this
relationship between the internet and
reality which I think it it's
established at this point yeah I would
just say it's not even just the left
it's it's really the the Department of
Homeland Security the doj the FBI no I I
agree that that are truly calling the
shots here and saying this idea is
banned sure but I think that I mean the
left it's a category that we use to
define something but ultimately like the
left is a counter-establishment you know
countervailing forces collapse because
all of its views align with the views of
the federal government and I mean to
your point about this I think in the in
the last two years or so Twitter removed
accounts for what it said was quote uh
undermining faith in NATO alliance in
NATO yeah it's on Twitter's official
page it says undermining faith in the
NATO well a lot of uh the Atlantic
Council also uh plays a lot of
fact-checking roles and uh curation
roles they censored a lot of people
critical of the US military industrial
complex many times many organizations
many individuals many reporters coming
out and it's the same as we saw on the
corporate media there's no anti-war
voices there and they're building a war
a world where there's going to be no
anti-war voices anywhere right so yes
and conveniently the like it just
happens to be the case that the left's
views and tendencies align with the
establishment's view so yep but it's
even further with the DHS coming to them
be like we're going to do this now
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time